I really hate to do this because
um he's a super nice guy who I've
actually had dinner with in a group and
we have a lot of contacts and friends in
common but Robert F Kennedy Jr Bobby
Kennedy Jr has launched a completely off
the rails presidential campaign based on
anti-vax opportunism and pro-putin
talking points and it's really really
sad that this is going on
um as I've mentioned before on the show
uh Bobby Kennedy Jr is sort of like
linked to other folks that are in
Progressive media and uh I once had
dinner with them in Las Vegas and he was
super nice and engaging told interesting
stories extraordinarily polite and just
a you know nice guy to be around and
then the pandemic hit and what has what
was before sort of a more casual
skepticism of vaccines became going
fully anti-vaxx recently pictured with
Michael Flynn just complete greatly
embraced by the most extreme
anti-vaccine elements and earlier this
month Bobby Kennedy filed his candidacy
making him the fourth member of his
family to seek the presidency of the
United States he had an event yesterday
in Boston in which he
um quite frankly ranted for 90 minutes
to the point where even people behind
him were starting to become visibly
uncomfortable here is Bobby Kennedy Jr
praising Donald Trump's instincts not to
close the country down during covet take
a listen
he knew that he shouldn't have closed
down the country
but he did it he got rolled by his
bureaucracy and I'm going to tell you a
quick story
during the Cuban Missile Crisis yeah
there were a lot of those Side Stories
which is why this thing ended up lasting
an hour and a half it is important to
mention that uh there is wide reporting
that many members of the Kennedy family
are supporting Joe Biden over Bobby
Kennedy Jr in the primary and I guess I
should mention Bobby Kennedy Jr running
as a Democrat although I don't really
know at this point sort of like what
policies line him up with the Democratic
party uh here is a clip sort of in the
middle of this extremely long 90-minute
rant and as you can see uh the folks in
the background their expressions have
changed pretty dramatically and it was
it was quite painful I will say I'm in a
lawsuit involving Amazon for censoring
one of my books so they were censoring
people who criticized the lockdowns
while they were raking in the money from
them and I it's hard not to laugh
because the the crowd he lost the crowd
the way Trump loses a crowd just going
on and on and yes he talks about he's
being censored and uh now he's he's
gonna fight back what censoring what on
Earth is going on here this is what this
is what happens when you censor somebody
for 18 years
I got a lot to talk about
they shouldn't have shut me up that long
because now I'm gonna really let loose
on them for the next 18 months they're
going to hear a lot from them
so listen I support anybody who wants to
challenge Joe Biden for the Democratic
nomination absolutely do it here's just
a guy who I I can't say is a better
alternative to me in absolutely anyway
he of course got the hero's welcome on
Tucker Carlson's program last night
after this very brave launching of an
anti-vax campaign for president and what
he did was he showed up on Tucker
Carlson's show and he repeated pro-putin
propaganda about death rates in the uh
invasion of Ukraine by Russia
nobody talks about this there's 14
000 Ukrainian civilians who have died
but 300 000 troops the Russians are
killing ukrainians at a seven to one to
eight to one ratio they cannot sustain
this well we're being told about this
war is just not true
no it's not true there you go so finding
common ground with the pro-putin people
and with Tucker Carlson this is a claim
based on a fake doctored report of
Russian propaganda
put out that has been conclusively uh
debunked and it is still being repeated
by Bobby Kennedy Jr to Tucker Carlson so
essentially an anti-vaxx pro-putin
campaign I guess it is truly sad to see
this Bobby Kennedy Jr not only a really
nice guy but a long history of powerful
work defending the environment
protecting the planet dealing with
climate change River Keeper Alliance uh
attorney working on these issues it's
genuinely depressing to see what has
happened with Bobby Kennedy Jr and also
I guess now at his rally his wife the
actress from Curb Your Enthusiasm and
other shows Cheryl Hines was there and
and introduced him and seemed to be
behind the whole thing there was quite a
bit of drama involving her during the
um the heart of the pandemic wherein
while Bobby Kennedy Jr was out rallying
railing against vaccines
Cheryl required everyone who went to
their holiday party to be vaccinated and
sort of it seemed as though maybe she
wasn't on board with the entire thing
but apparently now she is so this is not
a candidate I will be supporting I don't
yet know who I will be supporting in the
Democratic primary because I don't yet
know who all the candidates are going to
be uh Joe Biden has not even announced
that he is running for re-election so
when I know who I will be supporting I
will let you know the first step would
be let's figure out if Joe Biden is
actually running for reelection when
you're using websites and apps your
device sends out data about you into the
open who you are where you go things you
like that data then gets sold around for
advertising purposes which is why every
time I connect to the internet I use a
VPN to hide my IP address and our
sponsor private internet access is the
most trustworthy VPN on the market it's
the only VPN that has proven multiple
times in court they don't log your act
activity private internet access
protects you from the prying eyes of
hackers your internet service provider
tech companies private internet access
is also super fast for streaming and for
downloads you can watch your favorite
streaming platforms as if you're in
another country like the UK to access
cool new content and with just one
account you can protect unlimited
devices all at the same time this is
really a game changer private internet
access is giving my audience 83 percent
off that's 203 a month plus four months
free go to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link
is down below